welcome to the program we begin in
Indonesia where at least 174 people have
been killed in a stampede following a
contentious football match it happened
in the city of Malang after a match
between home team arima of FC and their
Rivals Surabaya the chaos began after
supporters from the losing side invaded
the pitch police responded by firing
tear gas which caused the crowd to flee
for the exits president Joko wododo has
ordered a review of security at football
matches
foreign I have specially requested the
police chief investigates and get to the
bottom of this case furthermore I have
also ordered the Indonesian Football
Association to temporarily halt League
one matches until evaluations and
improvements to the safety procedures
have been completed I regret this
tragedy and I hope this is the last
tragedy to occur in Indonesian football
we cannot have this anymore
sportsmanship humanity and Brotherhood
in the nation should be upheld together
Jessica Washington has the latest from
Jakarta
there were some disgruntled fans
disappointed with the outcome of the
match disappointed that the home team
lost and as they climbed onto the pitch
some 3 000 people the police attempted
to disperse the crowd attempted to stop
the incidence of violence that were
happening on the field and so they fired
tear gas and as a result the people
panicked and they rushed for the exits
there are some 16 exits at this Stadium
but it appears that people rushed to
their nearest exit as they tried to
leave the stadium and as a result there
was overcrowding there was a Stampede in
what we've heard from the local health
authority in Malang is that people died
as a result of being trampled on and
then suffocating Indonesian football has
a rather checkered history Indonesians
love football it is an extremely popular
sport here but at the same time the
sport has had a number of problems and
chief among those problems are the
issues of fan violence and fan
hooliganism there is intense rivalry
between these local clubs in the
Indonesian local league and that rivalry
often spills out into chaos into
violence and even into riots and so this
is really a common occurrence these
these violent incidents these riots at
football matches I have friends who are
involved as football coaches here in
Indonesia and they say that they
wouldn't feel comfortable even taking
their own family to these matches
because of the these incidents which
happen far too frequently
there's been a long history of stampedes
and riots at football games let's take a
look at some of the worst in the past
three decades writing after a match in
the Egyptian city of Portside in 2012
left 73 people dead and a thousand
injured the Egyptian League was
suspended for two years one of Africa's
worst football stampedes was in the
Ghanaian capital of Accra in 2001 around
126 were killed when police fired tear
gas at writing Spectators a stampede of
football fans at a 1996 World Carver
qualifying match in Guatemala City
killed up to 82 people crowns were
pushed downstairs and tumbled over seats
and 96 Liverpool supporters were crushed
to death at Hillsborough Stadium in the
British city of Sheffield in 1989 they
had been trapped in overcrowded and
fenced in inclusions
let's bring in Usman Hamid he's the
director at Amnesty International
Indonesia and he joins us from Bogle in
Indonesia Usman thanks so much for being
on the program firstly what's your
reaction to this deadly incident
sure really sure
[Music]
look I think we have lost Usman Hamid
we'll try and cross back to him a little
later in the program but for the moment
we'll move on